everybody says they miss the old me i've
been on this ride since i was 15. i
don't blame the girls for how i went
down down thinking out loud yeah camila
cabello doesn't blame the girls the
girls meaning fifth harmony i don't
blame the girls for how it went down
down it's a lyric from camila's new song
psycho freak off her latest album
familia out now it's just like very like
raw like everything about it i feel like
just very
true
in the track which features willow
camila addresses her 2016 exit from the
girl group in the second verse everybody
says they miss the old me i've been on
this ride since i was 15. i don't blame
the girls for how i went down
thinking out loud not only does she
mention the girls but the words down
down they're likely intentional too it's
the title of the first fifth harmony
song released without camila
[Music]
camila confirms to reuters that yes the
lyric is about her former bandmates and
explains quote that song is basically
about anxiety and all of the different
things that have made up my journey with
anxiety and starting off really young in
the industry
the 25 year old havana singer also says
she chats with her former bandmates here
and there and insists it's all love
quote we have been supportive of each
other through dms and stuff i'm in a
really good place with them
[Music]
fifth harmony first formed in 2012 on
the x factor but in 2016 the girls
announced camila left the group the
remaining members went on to tour for
nearly two more years until they all
went their separate ways in 2018 to
pursue solo careers ali brook told et in
2020 they're cheering for one another as
they do their own things and we support
each other whenever we can and
that's the best thing and everybody
honestly right now is just
on their own and living their own dreams
and camila she's already on album number
three a lot of people have told me like
this feels different than your other
albums and
in the sense that it feels more grounded
it feels more honest there was kind of
no barrier of like pressure or anxiety
or
you know it was just very like
unfiltered like it was just like
literally whatever i was feeling that
day
and i think that comes through in the
music
[Music]
but the bomb bomb singer isn't the only
one thriving solo i'm still
introducing myself and yes everybody
knows that i can
do the dance thing and i can
you know be this diva-s confident
uh entertainer but there's so much more
[Music]
fair i feel like it was really
the perfect record to
to be vulnerable and to
share my
most inner thoughts and feelings in the
meantime we'll be vibing to these new
hits and keeping our fingers crossed for
a collab or reunion someday you know
what everything happens for a reason and
i'm so proud of our work
and we were able to create songs that
are gonna last
forever